In this section of your ICFX training, we are going to move into a hands-on end display configuration and setup.
Now, this is going to be slightly different than the at-home setup, and as a result, we're going to take a look at our terminology again.
The end display component terminology that you should already be familiar with is going to be the same as we go ahead and build this out.
So we use NDC to abbreviate end display configuration when we talk about it.
We will talk about cluster, host, node, and viewport as we build out the end display configuration.
And then when we move into our camera discussion a little later, we'll talk about our frustum, inner and outer,
and then we'll also refer to the use of a pixel processor, which is our hardware system channeling from the end display configuration to the wall itself.
Now, the first time that we get our end display configuration set up, we will need to import some meshes.
The big difference between the end display configuration at home and the end display configuration for your stage
is that the stage requires a custom mesh. To import that, we're going to just import the FBX that we've created
and make sure that we import our game path and disable the generate lightmap UVs.
We're not using this for a light, so we aren't going to necessarily need those lightmap UVs.
Now, your stage is going to be a little bit different, your hardware configuration, your meshes are going to be different,
but the principles are going to be the same.
The first thing that we do is we need to create an end display configuration, then double click to open that new NDC configuration
that we've named NDC asset S01, because it's stage 01.
Once that's open, delete your end display screen. We'll be adding in new components with new meshes,
and we will also have created our offset when we created this.
Now, our stage, our offset is 170.2 units, and it's already built in using the DCC Maya to generate our meshes.
Your origin position, which is what our offset is, is going to be a little bit different.
We'll talk about that once we set that up.
Now, once we get our meshes in, we will set up our cluster.
Our cluster is going to run through the settings of our render sync policy.
The default sync policy is set to Ethernet.
That's required for larger stages, because this configuration typically has multiple hosts.
Now, as we go through and create our hosts, we're going to need to add in a new cluster node,
and we're going to have to set that with our render node and choose the IP address for the actual render node itself.
Once you click and create those, a multi-monitor configuration will require that we add together the pixel width
of all our monitors in that configuration.
The total pixel width is then input under the node 0 window in the menu of your details panel.
Next, we want to make sure that as we set up our cluster,
we will set up our viewports to match the layout of our physical wall.
The latte stage uses two hosts.
We have two hosts connecting our main LED wall, which is a side and main wall,
as well as a 4K TV wild wall that is running in a separate computer.
The way these layout is that we create our in-display viewports
and then position the pixels inside the pixel viewport
so that they match the same layout that we have on the Brompton for our mapping.
Now, there is a best practice that we want to talk about here.
As you build out your in-display configuration,
it is important that you generate an in-display sublevel
where all of your in-display configurations will be brought into the world.
They live in that world space,
and they should be brought into and parented underneath your persistent level.
Now, the MVC level itself should also be changed from blueprint to always loaded
so that it is always active in your persistent level.
Now, let's jump into the engine here.
Now, right as we get started, I'm going to start with our best practices.
You can see that we're in my beach level.
I've got a beach that's all set up.
This is the world that we're going to be living in.
To start off, I'm just going to create that level from the start.
Go into levels and create my MVC level.
Now, once this is ready to go, because I'm connected to Perforce,
I do want to make sure that I check out my stage level
and make sure that my MVC level is either set to add or ready to be added here.
Now, I move up from my outliner and switch tabs to my levels
to make sure that my MVC level gets added into my persistent level.
Now, with my persistent level active and my MVC level parented underneath,
I want to change my streaming method by right-clicking here
to change streaming method to always loaded.
Now, with the two levels here, I also have the option in my viewport
of switching between the two, since my MVC configuration
that I'm going to build must live in my MVC level,
I'm going to make sure that this is the active level in my viewport.
Next, I'm going to need a folder in my content browser
for my end display configuration to live.
So I'm going to right-click here and go ahead and add a new folder
and I'm going to call this one MDC.
And from there, I'm going to go ahead and add in a new folder
for organization called MDC Meshes.
Because as we start out here, we are going to need to bring in meshes to work from.
So let's start with our importing.
I'm going to open up this folder because that's where I want my meshes to live
and I'm going to right-click here and go ahead and import to game MDC meshes.
You'll see I've got wall meshes and wild wall in here.
So I'm going to first select my wall meshes and hit open.
And you'll see that there is a section here for generate lightmap UVs.
I want to make sure that this is checked off.
Go ahead and import all and that's going to bring in my meshes.
I can ignore this warning and get ready to bring in one more mesh.
So I'm going to do it again.
Import game MDC meshes and choose my wild wall 4K TV vertical mesh.
So that FBX is coming in.
Again, generate lightmap UVs is checked off.
I'm going to go ahead and import all.
And I'm going to get the same message for my error.
This message is really just saying no smoothing group is found.
That's fine. We're not going to be using that.
Now as I get ready to use this, I am going to need to make some changes to my meshes.
So let's go ahead and open up each one of these.
This shows me all of my meshes.
I'm going to move through each one of these from start to finish.
So here is my main wall.
In my main wall it has a UV channel 0 which is a full non-uniform UV unwrap of this wall.
And another UV channel which is a uniform layout of my UV channel.
Now this channel is used for color keying and green screen.
With this saved, I do want to make one change here.
My new meshes means that I need to go into my build settings underneath my LOD section under build settings
and turn on use full precision UVs.
Hit apply changes and then save this mesh.
Then I can close this window and move on to the next mesh.
Same thing with this one. This is my side walls position.
I'm going to go ahead and turn on use full precision UVs and apply those changes.
Save this mesh and move on to the last one.
Now I'm not checking my channels but I know that my channels are correct.
UV channel 0 and UV channel 1, they are laid out this way.
Now I don't want them overlapping as well.
You'll notice that this UV channel 1 is in the upper corner and the previous mesh was in the lower corner.
That's because if I'm using these I don't want them to overlap.
So again I'm going to save and move on to my final mesh.
My final mesh is my wild wall.
Same thing, turn on use full precision UVs, apply my changes and look at my UV sets.
Now my wild wall has a full non-uniform scale layout for my UV set.
This is fine. I want to keep this but since my wild wall is not going to be using a UV channel 1
and its UV sets aren't perfect, I'm going to go ahead and remove this selected UV channel.
The wild wall doesn't use chroma key that much unless your wild wall is using chroma key.
You don't need this.
So I'm going to go ahead and delete it and hit save and then I can close this window.
Now you can see I've got these all added.
I'm going to go ahead and make sure that my Lambert also gets added to my source control by hitting mark for add.
Now back to my NBC folder, I need to start work on my end display configuration.
To do that I'm going to right click, move up to the end display section in my content browser and create end display config.
Now I'm going to want to create a new configuration and go ahead and hit finish here.
Now with this new configuration, I'm going to call this MDC asset because that's what this is.
And I'll call this S for stage and 01.
Now once that's ready to go, I am going to need to edit this and make sure that my meshes show up.
So first thing, I want to open this up and I'm going to pull it off so it's minimized a little
so it's just not taking up the whole space of the screen because I want to move back into my NDC meshes folder
and grab each of these to add into my end display configuration.
Now as I get started, you are going to find out that right away you'll see that there is this mesh.
This is our end display screen.
Because this is a generic screen and we use this for at home, I'm actually going to delete this because we need a custom mesh for our stage setup.
So my custom mesh is going to take the place of those and I'm going to do that by clicking on them and dragging them in.
Now you would think I'd be able to add components, but I can't.
In order to actually add these, I'm going to go ahead and grab all of them and drag them up to the MDC asset.
Now I do need another component here for organization.
That component, if I select my NDC asset, is going to be an end display transform, which I'm just going to call NDC xform.
Or actually let's change this to xform walls.
And I'm going to call it that because I'm going to parent my two meshes from my main wall underneath them.
So that as I'm organized, my wild wall is separate from that position.
Now as I go through here, one of the things I want to do right away is I want to make sure that my wild wall 4K TV is going to be a tracked object.
So while I'm in here, before I get anything else set up, let's add in that component.
So let's go live link and I'm going to add in a live link component controller.
Now that's a lot of words, so I'm going to make this an abbreviation for LL for live link underscore CC for component controller.
And I'm going to call this one wild wall WW 4K TV track.
TRK is for tracking.
Now I'm ready to go in here and it's time to move on to building out our end display configuration.
So you see here that's step one, that gives us all of our components.
And I'm going to go through each of my wall mesh pieces.
And I'm going to make sure that everything is correct in here in my settings.
And then I'm going to move on down to my component controller.
And in order to get this to actually work, I'm going to make sure that my subject representation chooses my wild wall 4K TV first.
And that the subject is ready to go.
Where did I get the selection?
If I go under source and choose OptiTrack source, I have this create option.
That's going to allow me to create this.
And you'll see that I've got an already predefined wild wall 4K TV and a Blackmagic Active for our camera.
As well as a nodal plug for our tracked object that we'll use later in calibration.
Now back into my details panel and back into my end display configuration.
This you can see my wild wall representation exists again and I'm ready to compile this.
Now I haven't set up cluster nodes because you can see my compiler results are going to be wrong.
Now I need to do that.
I need to move over to step two and start building in my clusters.
Now let's go ahead and add in our first cluster.
So here's my new cluster node.
I'm going to add this cluster node and I'm going to call this one RNDR for render as it's my first node.
And add in a zero for a double zero.
Now my preset here is a full HD 1920 by 1080.
I'm going to change this to quad, I'm sorry to ultra HD because the monitor that I'm using is an ultra HD 3840 by 2160.
That is what spread across the entire pixel mapping for our pixel processor software.
So selecting this I need to also change my IP address.
Now at home using a generic IP address is fine but on a stage you're generally going to want to use the IP address for the machines that you're connecting to.
So that first IP address is going to be 10 dot 14 dot 101 dot 70.
That's for our render node.
I'm going to go ahead and make sure that this is all set and my position for my size is 3840 by 2160.
So I'm going to go ahead and hit add.
Now I'm going to zoom to fit so you can see what's going on in here.
And you can see I've got my host with my IP address, my render node with my primary position in here.
And down here is my viewport where we're going to make some changes.
So first thing I'm going to do is change my view origin in my details panel to the default viewpoint.
Next under my projection policy I want to change from simple to mesh.
Now changing from simple to mesh I need to choose a mesh to connect this to.
So that first mesh is going to be my wall main.
With my wall main selected you can see that my mesh position actually shows up in here.
Now this wall mesh is not actually the right size.
My viewport is actually going to need to be smaller.
So I'm going to change that number to 1760 by 880.
Now that doesn't change what's projected in here.
It just changes the position inside my cluster node.
Now the position in here needs to match the layout that we showed you earlier for my end display configuration.
Which means I need to move this over by changing my position to 2080.
So that this aligns in that position.
I'm going to keep zero because we want it to be flush against this edge.
Now I need to rename this so viewport zero's name changes.
We're going to call this main wall VP for viewport.
And then with that selected I'm just going to go ahead and hit control D.
Now if this doesn't work for you, you can go ahead and right click and duplicate as well.
But hitting control D should make a duplicate viewport that we can then make more adjustments to.
First adjustment, let's rename this so we don't get confused.
This is going to be our side wall.
I'm going to take off the VP1 and just leave this as side wall VP.
Now I'm going to change my mesh here from wall main to wall side.
That changes what it's being looked at.
And now I just need to change my position and my size.
My position back to zero.
And my size needs to be 880 because that side wall is smaller than our main wall.
Now note, it stretches this out.
If I hit 1760 again, it stretches this position out.
But it doesn't change what's being shown in here.
But the 880 is the correct orientation.
Next, I need to move into my wild wall and do the same thing.
Now I could add the wild wall here, but because it's running on a separate host and a separate node,
I need to add to that cluster.
So before I do that, I'm going to select my cluster.
Let's go add, new cluster node.
And for this one, I'm going to change the name here to that new machine.
That's going to be MLTP for multipurpose.
I'm going to add an 01 here because it's the second node in our set, and we started with zero.
And this one also is a Ultra HD 3840 by 2160.
One of the things I can do here is I need to first add in my host IP address, 10.14.101.65.
And then on this, you'll notice that I've got a size position in here.
Now this wild wall is vertical.
I could make these changes later, but I'm going to make them now.
I'm going to change this 2160 to 3840 in a vertical position.
So I'm just reversing these two.
Now with that done, I'm ready to go.
So I can go ahead and hit add.
This gives me my full vertical position.
And I really want to make sure that I just change my viewport here.
So let's change that name.
Wild wall 4K TV viewport.
Now select that again.
Make sure that my view origin is set to default.
My type here is mesh.
And that my mesh that's selected is my wild wall 4K TV.
Now I'm not going to make any changes here on my size.
The thing that you're seeing here is a positional change that's collapsing in here.
It's because of where it is on my default viewpoint and my origin.
To fix this, all I got to do is move it.
So I'm going to move this position.
I'm going to move this over.
And initially, I really want to make sure that this is just set kind of where I want it to be.
Now as I put these in position, there is something else that needs to get added.
And that's going to change our position.
So I'm not going to get married to this really quickly.
Now that asset that needs to be added here is selecting my NDC asset and going to add ICVFX camera.
You need the ICVFX camera to show where your camera is actually going to be looking inside your nDisplay configuration.
We'll make these adjustments a little bit later, but we're going to call this NDCICVFXCam.
And we're going to leave this in here.
Now we're using only one camera right now, so we don't need to iterate this.
Now with that ICVFX camera, you can see that my wall's position is not exactly where I want it to be.
This is where the X form comes into play.
Like if I wanted to rotate this wall, it's going to rotate its position based on just that wall.
And I don't want that.
I only want these two to move together.
So let's select my rotation and rotate it 90 degrees to make sure that that's lined up and that's facing the correct position.
Now my wild wall needs to adjust as well.
Where my wild wall lives currently is not quite where I want it to be.
So let's rotate this 90 degrees and maybe zero that back out.
Now if I look at that, it's not really where I want it to be, and it's not facing the right direction either.
So let's negative 90 this, or negative 180 this actually, if I could just type.
There we go, 180.
And then these positions are going to change.
For this, 50 is probably enough, it's close enough.
250 here gets me closer, and then another 50 to raise it up.
So that's a little closer to where we're actually located in the real world space.
Now with this all set, I'm ready to hit compile and save.
Now note, as you go through here, if something's not quite right, you can always go back and make adjustments.
So if I'm looking here in my configuration and under my cluster, I find that maybe my render sync policy isn't quite correct or it hasn't been set to Ethernet.
I can go ahead and adjust that.
At home, you don't necessarily need to use Ethernet.
If you switch to none, that's fine because you're using your local position.
But if you're using a stage, larger stages have multiple nodes with multiple configurations, you're going to want to make sure that this uses the default Ethernet configuration under your cluster's render sync policy.
Now if I come through here and I'm like, you know what, some of this might not be right, maybe my IP address is wrong, I can always go in and change these later to make sure that I'm connecting to the correct position.
Now once this is done, I'm going to go ahead and hide this for now and move back into my level.
Now back in here, I've got my nDisplay asset, I've got my maps, and I'm in my nDisplay level.
From here, I want to make sure that I add in my nDisplay configuration and see that that's going to get added in.
And since I can't see anything, I've got to figure out where it went.
Now that just means that this mesh has inherited some of these positions, and I'm going to go ahead and zero this out and zero out my rotations.
And then I need to move my mesh, which is actually going to be located way over here at my origin position, back to where I need to be inside my level.
So let's go ahead and keep that pretty close, move that around, just kind of get right in front, and then zoom in a little bit closer.
So we're back in front of our cave, let's rotate this, and move these into position.
Now, my Live Link wild wall is actually going to be controlling this positional information, so this is going to be something that gets controlled inside Motive.
So I just want to move this back a little bit, and you can see whatever is being shown in here is actually going to be what's displayed on our screen.
So it's important that you have these positions already set.
Now, let's jump back into our slides really quick.
All right, so let's take a look again at the Latte stage and the viewport regions and its relationship to the Pixel processor.
So the setup that we have for quick visual reference on our Render CPU, which you'll see on the right side here,
is laid out with our side wall, which if you're standing in front of the physical wall, the side wall is on the left,
and the main wall is dead center, but it's positioned on the right, it's to the right of our wall.
Now, for our pixel resolution on our Render CPU, we lay them out the same way for quick visual reference.
This means that in our Pixel processor for the in-display configuration, that same mapping feed is laid out to match.
That way, the side wall lines up with the main wall on the pixel resolution feed,
and as you'll see in our next slide, these line up with our in-display configuration,
matches our physical world LED walls, and our in-display configuration matches our render output node,
so that they line up correctly.
This matches our Brompton, as we've shown before, and if we switch over to the Brompton,
you can see that this map lays out in the exact same configuration.
So that's it for your in-display configuration.
Next up, we'll be adding in some cameras and discussing our frustrum.